hundreds of brides and grooms across the
country are canceling or postponing
their weddings due to the coronavirus we
are hearing that a lot a Facebook group
called wedding disaster support kovat 19
already has more than 2400 members and
still growing Meg Oliver reports from
outside a bridal shop in Montclair New
Jersey also pronounced bridal shop where
the sign on the door I hate when I do
that where the sign on the door has a
jarring message
the sign says the shop is only allowing
in one bride at a time with two guests
like many the wedding industry is being
disrupted by coronavirus we spoke to a
couple who had to postpone their wedding
but they weren't about to delay becoming
husband and wife this is not the wedding
day Lauren and Jacob Greenough
envisioned but it's a day they vowed to
never forget plans yes we spoke to the
bride and groom just minutes before
their I Do's at a courthouse in Virginia
a far cry from their 300 acre wedding
venue in Maryland they rushed to tie the
knot Monday shortly after canceling
really what's the point of all this is
we want to be together so we're excited
for that hopefully we'll be able to
celebrate with everybody else
later earlier this week the president
released guidelines calling for people
to avoid gathering in groups of more
than 10 people to help stop the spread
of the corona virus Collett rishu and
her fiance chris morton have been
planning their New York wedding for more
than a year now they're trying to find a
new date Zola and the knot two of the
most popular wedding websites are
encouraging couples affected by
cancellations or postponements to reach
out to them for assistance they've also
been offering tips to couples like
designating someone to help them call
guests about the change in plans and
talking to vendors to see if the wedding
date can be moved
without a financial hit but a financial
hit is something wedding vendors and
businesses fear too this is unchartered
territory for sure
Liz Selassie owns designer loft Bridal a
wedding dress shop in New York City
I think March is where it's gonna be
we're gonna be decimated much much
quieter Selassie is fielding constant
calls from panicked brides and their
mothers who are dealing with postponed
weddings we will work with those brides
we're holding a lot of dresses for girls
that have had to postpone we're all in
this together
[Music]
Kenzie ray McMullen a wedding
photographer in Florida he's also doing
her best to work with brides who she
says are mostly rescheduling for the
fall McMullen who was immune-compromised
also worries about her own health I have
a bride who is planning to go forward
with her wedding as far as we know right
now and I'm there for my brides but
going out to a wedding or any gathering
even if it's only 50 people is still
more dangerous for me
brides like reshoe told us health is
most important she's come to terms with
postponing her wedding and has a message
for other brides anything we can control
we Shu and her fiance are still
considering getting married on their
original date but with a much smaller
group we also talked to other couples
who expressed concerns over refunds and
rescheduling difficulties with their
venues the knot advises reading your
contract closely and calling a lawyer if
necessary for CBS this morning Meg
Oliver
New Jersey